hey everybody it's mike
and it's three o'clock so i'll get
started um
today's presentation is going to be on
flow edges um
and i'm gonna give you a brief sort of
you know say say groundwork but you
don't want to explain about the flow
edges i'm going to show you
the indicator in action and then at the
end i'll take questions so i'll
um
get to you know whatever questions you
have in the chat i'm not going to stop
in between to take a look at them
because it just sort of throws me off
track but i'll get them at the end but
marshall um
i do see your message there
and i'll i'll i'll resend you the the
information but um
but for everybody else uh i just want
you know we'll get to the uh questions
at the end of the presentation
all right so
flow edges what is flow edges well it's
the new indicator that we've released
and
it basically
looks at order flow differently than all
the other tools that i've released in
the past okay and i'm going to sort of
break it down in a minute and again
what we're going to be doing today
today's agenda i'm going to try to keep
it to an hour i don't you know sometimes
these presentations
there's a lot of questions and and i try
to get to all of them and
you know hopefully it won't take more
than an hour but you know we might go an
hour hour 15. i don't think it should
take more than an hour and a half
now i'm gonna explain what flow edges is
and what it means in the market how to
use flow edges to get the most out of it
right because you know
honestly i look around you know i see
these other indicators i'm on
everybody's list as well so you know i
always get
you know bombarded with uh emails you
know about new tools new indicators but
they don't really go into how to use
them right and it kind of bothers me
because of them look kind of interesting
and that's why i like to do these
presentations so you can understand how
to use it and
you know see it rather than you know
having two or three pictures posted up
on a web page and then trying to figure
it out by yourself
and i talk about what the settings mean
and how to adjust them based on your
style of trading you know because
everybody's got different styles of
trading and
every market
has its own little unique nuances to it
and i take you through some of the
different
chart types and you know sort of explain
um
you know how to best use order uh flow
edges with
those different chart types and spend
some time talking about trading in the
evening session an overnight
session because you know i realize a lot
of people have
things they're doing during the day
whether it's you know a regular
full-time job or you know managing the
kids
and they can only trade at night but you
know that doesn't mean that you can't
trade you know the asian hours or the
european hours um with order flow you
can because there's still plenty of
order flow
for
a trader to analyze
so
really what flow edges does is it helps
traders know when a market has found
value and balance and is beginning to
move away from
balance okay it's one thing for a market
to find value okay then that's going to
find its balance but it's going to move
away from there eventually right we're
not going to always stay
in a value right in a value area so to
speak right market's always looking for
new areas of value
and
when most traders think of value in the
market right they think of market
profile
and they think of
volume profile
okay and there's nothing wrong with that
but
the way that most traders look at volume
profile market profile is just
top day right just
how it's developing for the day
okay and then what you're doing is
you're sort of restricting yourself to
this
window of time right this well you know
today's value very high today's value
area low so to speak and when we're
within value you know but oftentimes
market moves away from the value area
and you have this you know if the market
is rallying
and we're outside the value area what
well you have where's your reference
points in terms of value well
the the thing is
that if you're constricting yourself to
this day time frame you're sort of
leaving out all this this other time
frame analysis so to speak right because
you know
the big traders you know i don't like to
say the long term traders etc but
sort of the other time frame traders the
people other than day traders right that
they're looking at a day
uh
time profile right for the day's trading
day you know these are people that could
hold positions for
two days three days a week
a month
longer right and
really those are the traders that are
going to really move the market now
there are big
size day traders that
can put pressure on the market
you know that whose activity during the
day
um you know can cause the markets to
react but generally it's this
the big money that's coming in you know
the people with deeper pockets
than you know the people that are
trading
um you know mostly on margin and
they're not going to really move the
markets very far the markets really move
due to you know the other time frame
traders you know the the big traders
that are managing money
um
you know that have to park it somewhere
and when they come into the market
that's really what causes the market to
move now this is where market analysis
gets interesting
because there's no single time based
chart or volume based chart or tick
based chart or whatever that every
trader looks at the same right every
trader
has their own time frame right
my time frame that i look at on a chart
it's probably different than what you're
looking at on a chart
and
trying to wrap up all those different
time frames into a single profile leaves
a lot out
okay so a day's profile only covers at
this day i talk about profiles
because that's how a lot of traders
define value right and balance what
happens is what happens when the market
finds that value so
just as not all traders use the same
chart type
not all traders are defining value the
same way right because they're not all
looking at the same profile
if everybody sat down and looked at the
same profile
sure every time the market hits the
value area high it would sell off
revert back into the value area
maybe sell down to the you know then
everybody's got a bid down at the value
area low right to buy it when it comes
down to the value very low for a move
back into
the the point of control or you know the
midpoint of value
but not every trader looks at that same
profile okay
i know not all traders use a profile
okay and again i talk about it in terms
of profile but
that's one of the ways to see
where value is developing quickly and
easily because it's very visual
but there are other ways to see where
value is forming in the order flow the
point
the important part is to understand
where value is forming and it's not just
forming
on a five-minute chart or it's not just
forming on a 30-minute chart
or a daily chart right there's so many
different layers of where value can be
find found in the market
you know it's it's
one of those things where you could
literally open up a chart
and start plotting where you're seeing
value coming in right now
right it's there's no
defined way in a sense that says no you
have to you know to find value you have
to start your charting at um you know
when the market opens up and the day
closes
at the day no there's so many different
levels and layers
inside that that you can find value
and this is what flow edges does it
looks for areas where traders have
defined as value based on the market
generated information
now
i love candlestick charts i've always
liked candle just stick charts ever
since i started trading you know back in
the 90s um you know sort of you know
when candlesticks you know really came
to the forefront in america
and
you know they're very easy to understand
deal markets going up markets going down
but they leave out a lot of information
that matters to traders right that's why
i use order flow right and i made the
switch to order flow
just because
you know back when electronic trading
started you know globex then we're
staring at a dome and then i understood
a lot clearer
you know the difference of you know in
those days when the market you know
globex only traded
outside of the market hours back then
and
you could literally see the difference
of a big order coming in and its effect
that it had on the market so you know
for anybody say well you know volume
doesn't matter well no it does it
matters a lot
okay
you want to see what other traders are
doing in the market where they are doing
it
and how they're doing it right and order
flow and specifically flow edges
answers these questions right and those
are important questions that
you you want to
have answered
okay so now we're going to take a look
at
you know some charts because i want to
you know take you through
sort of the
you know the the process that
that you go through with um
flow edges so you know i'll start here
in in the russell right because this
morning i sent out a chart
i'm talking about russell in the night
session
okay now night session is interesting
okay i want to get to that a little bit
later but
you know sometimes
these markets that are a little bit
difficult to trade during the days you
know during the normal trading hours
trade nicely at night you know things
like nasdaq which has people pulling
their hair out during the during the
normal session
is is a great market to trade in the
evening session because it's it's a
little bit more i don't say i don't use
the term stable
but um
you know it's a bit
more calm right you don't get these
exaggerated moves so much that you would
see uh during the normal hours but you
know what we'll sort of cover that
a bit later
now
so russell we'll start with russell um
because it's the chart that i have open
here first so
the settings of the flow edges right i
sort of talked about what goes in to it
here earlier but
make this a little smaller get this up
why can't i drag you there we go
um
let's put it
here so you know
first thing i do is enter your your
license
and enable it
basically two settings that you're
really going to be worrying about that
you have to deal with on a regular basis
on
flow edges and it's the flow edge level
and it's the swing strength
okay
now
the
base setting right the the starting
point and it's a level that's good for
most markets
okay now you can refine it you can make
a little bit stronger for other markets
and i'm going to take you through that
um but it's basically between one and
five
okay then there's the swing strength
right which is
default is set to zero
now flow edge level
can't be zero
it won't work i mean honestly if you had
the flow edge level at zero then
basically it's the same as not even
running the indicator um
but between one and five one being the
base five being
the strongest okay so with one
obviously you're going to get more
signals
so basically think of it in terms of one
three and five okay with two and four
sort of being you know mid points
between the low end
and four being the midpoint between the
higher end
okay now there's another thing in here
it's called the trade parameters and
it's
the third choice here it says enable
trade signal so if you enable it
you'll see
two sub choices here trade valid in bars
or number of bars trade entry in ticks
you see two and two so what that means
is
if there's a signal
right based on
the flow edges
for
or sorry if the conditions are met for
flow edges to
be generated
a signal won't print
until you get
the market moving in that direction of
the order flow okay
so it's got to move by two ticks trade
entry and ticks over the next two bars
and if it doesn't
do that then it won't print
a signal okay so for example
you see
right over here right there's a blue bar
right so it means the conditions are met
for
a trade entry potentially
but the next bar doesn't have any follow
through order flow and the next bar
doesn't
okay so it doesn't print the blue
triangle here right like you see
here or down here
and you know if there's
for example here's a cell
okay
this
um it's a dark red it looks brown
right over here
you'll see no down triangle there
because the next two bars didn't start
moving in that direction
now here's a blue bar right which is a
by you don't see a triangle coming in
over the next two bars a buy signal
because they didn't move in that
direction over the next two bars now
you don't have to use two bars i like to
use two bars
you could use one you could use three
so for example right if you change it
right now i've got two and two so if i
were to change it you know the three
bars right there's no signal on this buy
over here
if i were to change it
to um three now you'd see the buy signal
coming in right here
again it's up to you what you want to
use you want to use
two bars or three bars or you want to
use two ticks or
or one tick you know i know some people
like to use
uh one bar one tick meaning they want
the market to move immediately right it
has to start moving immediately in the
next bar you know
um it really depends on your trading
style you'll personally i find you know
if a market's not moving quickly
like within the next in like the next
two bars then you know i'm not really
interested in taking that trade but um
yeah i'll just set it back to two and
two
but that's what the trade entry signal
now you could turn this off right by
disabling it okay so
if i disable it
anytime there's
a signal
basically it will print
every time those conditions are met
rather
in the order flow
then
it will print
the the buy signal or the cell signal so
you can see it's printing here whereas
before it didn't and here is printing
that cell whereas before it didn't
now again it's up to you whether you
want to use it or not i just find that
generally if the market is not moving
quickly
like
now
then
it's probably not going to be a good
trade so you know that would have kept
me out of this trade here would have
kept me out of this trade would have
kept me out of this trade obviously
would have kept me out of this trade
which i'm fine with right i've
i've i
know my trading style
i know my
past performance and i i just find for
me personally
the best trades are the trades
that happen immediately
right and you know i say immediately but
within the next two bars
you know i just find it works best for
me now
so going back to
some of these settings like i said
setting one
is the base
setting and it's good for pretty much
every market as a starting point okay
you can play around with it you know you
could find a um
a stronger level
you know maybe you know some markets
and you know depending if you're using a
very quick chart you might want to use a
higher level right three or something so
for example let's
go to um
let's go to crude oil real quick here
and i got a crude chart so this is a one
minute chart i'll go down to a very a
quicker time frame of uh
30 seconds okay 30 seconds very fast
move and mark it moving chart
and
you know just sort of give you an idea
so right now the setting on this is set
to
one okay which is you know basically the
the base setting right
the starting point for
pretty much for everything
and you can see let me get the
crosshairs up here all right you can see
there's signal coming in here a buy
signal a sell signal another cell signal
you're not getting a buy here or by here
because you're using the trade entry
signal even though the conditions are
met
right then a cell some more cells down
in here now
if i were to
bump up the level
maybe you know go from one to three
which is again sort of the
mid strength level
right i mean one is your average
strength three is
you know higher five is the highest
um
you know how's it going to look well
let's take a look here so change it
and it's not much change you know it's
still pretty much giving you the same
signals
here here i think there was a short here
also it gave before
you're catching these shorts here but
now if you bump it up to five
the strongest
you're going to see
less signals
okay so now you just see the cell signal
here a cell signal here a cell signal
here now
you know if you
expand it here right you don't see
any signals coming in
this period here there's one cell signal
here but this period between you know
851 and you know basically 950
let me expand it here
on this chart
okay i'll go from 8 30. let's go from 8
30 here
until about 10 o'clock so 8 to 10 right
a setting of 5
no signals
now setting a 1
right
you're going to see some signals come in
okay like here you got a cell signal
here
and there was a buy here that didn't
work out or not didn't work out but
didn't have the the follow through order
flow
just as here you didn't the sell signal
no that would trade what stopped you out
so you're seeing you know one cell here
uh we'll sell here this buy it's a
little move up here um you know and some
back and forth and that's with the base
setting now
there's a few
other settings you can adjust
as well i'll say a few there's one other
is the swing strength okay
basically one is to disable it
i'm sorry zero is to disable it one
would be the lowest swing strength
so you know people ask me what's a good
swing strength well it really depends
on you do you want more signals or less
signals the higher you go with swing
strength
is going to
lower the amount of signals you're going
to get so
you know if i said it it was called
three
all right
gonna be again
less signal so before you know before
you're seeing a cell signal coming in
here it's not there
all you have is this one buy here
a cell here a buy here
um
it's a little hard to see on this chart
in the cell here the buy here
and then going back to that period where
we had you know a bunch of cells and
some bias you're not getting much going
on in there right there's less signals
all right even in here less
signals you got one signal here a bi
here a cell up here
hang on let me drink some water
now
you know so
that's crude and you know if you're
looking at
say e-minis
okay so i got the base setting of
one right and this has got the look-back
period
or the swing period strength the same
thing
um some indicators we call it the look
back period but basically the swing
period you're looking for swing
swing highs and swing lows
so this is the 30-second e-mini chart
all right so you got a cell here
a little move there um
no just not many
signals right there's an actual signal
here this triangle you'll notice you see
the bars but there's no follow through
order flow
and the reason why i developed that
trade entry signal and had it programmed
in there is because
you know before
when i would trade right and i'd get a
signal okay say okay i got a short
signal here right but there's no
up or down you know no down triangle for
the cell
now
it's one thing to have a signal right
because
you know the order flow happened in this
bar and it was bearish
based on you know all the other analysis
but
okay that's one thing but you know that
what happens next
isn't up to you
right you can do all the analysis in the
world
and think that okay yeah
the market's got to sell off based on my
analysis okay well no it doesn't because
once you get into the position it
doesn't matter what you think anymore
right you're sort of you can't control
it it's everybody else
that's basically now controlling your
your outlook of the market right you
you did all the work
okay market says it's ready to sell off
well all the other traders sitting
around you got other ideas
all right and you can even see here the
order flow came back bullish two bars
later so if
everybody else is sort of thinking
opposite of you the market's not going
to go down right if you're thinking oh
the market's bearish
all right that's why i use the trade
interesting because what i found is okay
yeah i've got something in the order
flow that's that's bearish
that's why we color the bar
dark red
or blue
but
if the market doesn't start moving in
that direction
then there's no follow-through order
flow
because you know i i know what it's like
right i i used to be a big trader right
i used to work at jp morgan i used to
work at cargill on the training desk
trading and
you know and
you see
you know i traded big orders my
colleagues trade big orders
you know sometimes i'd be sitting there
watching the market they can ask about
the sell-off and then boom the market
rallies well then i look over and it's
al just bought
you know is in the process of buying a
thousand e-minis
okay well i don't know that right i said
i do all my analysis i turn bearish
and i'm like okay waiting for the market
start you know heading in that direction
but if somebody else that's got a lot
more
um
money so to speak or you know a lot more
size all of a sudden decides that you
know it's a good buy
opportunity then the market's not going
to sell off because that person that big
trader is going to take the market
higher
at least in the short term i mean the
market may eventually sell off i mean it
rallied all the way up here before it
settled off
but
right now
the other person sitting on another
computer somewhere in the world
if if he doesn't you know if he's the
one that right now can influence the
market over the next
10 15 20 minutes
but he's thinking opposite of you no
matter what analysis you do whether it's
order flow or there's fibonacci whether
it's
any other you know phases of the moon it
doesn't matter
right other people have to also share
your opinion
so you can see you know getting short
here just because the order flow
conditions were met they don't follow
through order flow market went up she's
like here bearish order flow initially
but
no follow-through market went up finally
you got the bearish order flow again
but now
you have pretty much everybody else
thinking yeah
it's
you know it's bearish order flow okay
and what happens market sells off from
46.50
you know 50 and a half you know
somewhere in here 50 to 50 and a half
all the way down to 45 here
right well down here is 40 you know
five and a half where the bullish order
flow came in right in here
right that's that move
now
i sort of got
digressed a little bit but
right now right flow edge level one
swing strength of three okay so it's
taken into account with the swing
strength it's taking into account
um you know swing activity in the market
right it's looking for
um
as opposed to momentum okay i mean
there's basically different types of
trading right there's momentum based
trading which you know is a move that's
happening you want to jump in as quickly
as possible if you're more of a momentum
person you'd enter zero there right
leave it at zero don't use the swing
strength but you know if you're someone
that wants to try and find um
you know reversals in the market
so to speak use the swing strength you
know put a level in there
you really don't need to go over
20 but you know personally i use one
three
five
and nine
okay
um
people say why nine
this just goes back to the old tom the
mark sequential things
with with nines say i've always got
stuck on nines for some reason i could
use ten
honestly there's not much difference i i
didn't notice any big difference in all
of my testing
over the years of you know whether using
9 or or 10
on that swing strength but
you know zero if we want momentum
um one three five
nine now
if you're a momentum trader right and
yeah so you have it set at zero for
swing strength and using a low flow edge
level one you're gonna get a lot of
signals may not be evident so much on
e-minis
but if you're you're looking at
something like
dao
mnq
right you're going to see a lot more
signals
so you can see signals here right buy
you know sell buy again
buy we should already be long you know
sell a buy
buy
it's
you probably
you know for one you're going to get a
lot more trades period
and if you're using a 30-second chart um
you know it's very fast action it's
something you've got to be in tune with
right and
you know the
brain
personally i believe
you know a person has sort of their
their peak mental ability for a short
period of time right you can't sit down
at the market at
um you know 7 a.m in the morning and
trade until three in the afternoon
at 100 capacity of your brain um
there's usually
a period in there where you're gonna you
know an hour two hours
where
know you're you're at full strength
right because you know if if you're
trading a very quick chart right and you
have
you're getting a lot of signals in this
case you know using the base level of of
one and zero
to trade this entire day you know you're
gonna
you're gonna wipe yourself out
emotionally mentally
um
because you gotta you know in and out in
and out in and out so you probably don't
want to do that right you should go on
to
either a longer chart
or
again you'll use a swing strength or
even
set
a higher strength
um you know for example
well let's see what it looks like at the
highest strength five
right flow edge level maximum strength
five
okay so you're seeing you know a lot
less signals right there's a cell here
nice little selloff here the cell
just went sideways on you okay so you're
seeing how before
the very base level a lot of signals
no
not so much
so
let's sort of segue into
another another market here ultra bonds
right ultrabond's great market for
trading
but
you know this is sort of going to give
me an opportunity to talk a little bit
more about
the flow edge now
the thing with order flow right
you need market activity okay
it might be a little bit hard to see on
this
on your screen
but
these are actually
flat lines you know basically the market
traded one price one price one price one
price
and you know there's nothing to analyze
there in terms of order flow in context
of the market because it's just trading
the bid or the offer right it's trading
the bid and then turns you know trades
the offer there's nothing to be had in
that information
and
the flow edges
needs a little bit you know needs more
information fed into it right so you
know these bars that especially on a
market that's quiet right a market
that's going sideways
you're not going to get much information
oftentimes because especially in
interest rates
um you know
especially if you go down to something
like like the 10 years
where it's just
you know it's like
five five and a half you know three
thousand by four thousand right big
massive size
um so
you know on some markets for example
like
ultra bonds even burns to a certain
extent you know you need a little bit
range expansion in a bar
right so having a bar where it basically
trades
the bid you know you have bid an offer
maybe trades one tick above the offer or
one tick below is not going to be enough
and it the flow edges takes that into
account
and it's waiting for more more
information um you know to base this
trading decision on
so
you know what you can
you know i don't say what you can do but
what i do taking that into account i
know that
one minute
in certain markets for example um buns
to a lesser extent ultra bonds but
definitely 10 years five years it's not
going to give you enough range to
form a decent bar so
you know i just go to the next increment
up you know a two minute now ultra bonds
i do use on a one minute but i just want
to
show you
sort of
you know the difference
right you can see here so now you're
getting you know nicer
movement in the market
right
get much nicer movements you know downs
you can see these little triangle downs
here this is even in the
overnight session at the asian chest and
the asian
session
um
you see here it's almost you know from
10197.06
straight down to
196.20
um this is by just by going up you know
another time this was actually this was
yesterday this is a
beautiful move down starting you know
down down down down down you got a buy
signal here
and then just basically you know sell
again you know this buy that didn't work
out and came right back with the cell
and just
down and i'm not saying yeah you know
you would have that nice four point you
know
this is about this is from 200 all the
way down to 196.
i'm not saying you would have got that
but you know having a move like this
whereas if you're looking on a
and just go back to a a one minute chart
here
that time period
you know you seen a few signals in here
but on the two minute it was a little
bit more pronounced
you know coming down
and
let's go back to the two minute here
real quick
just sort of go back now again this is
with the base setting of
one
okay but
and you'll notice right let me i i don't
like to
i kind of didn't want to use this day as
an example but this trend was a good
example so i'll just sort of cut off
that part down here at the bottom
but you'll see
right some buys
in here some buys in here
you know by in here
when you up the strength right by upping
the strength
of
flow edge levels from one
to three
put that out of the way here
right notice
you know there was some buys earlier
there was a buy down here which is now
now no longer here
and you know i'm i'm happy to
well not happy i'm willing to
take this by here
and get stopped out and then get short
here to capture those nice runs right
they are really trading oftentimes is
about catching
and catching those runs when they happen
now again i'm not going to talk that
yeah you would have sold it here at 190
you know
at 200 and then covered at 196 i mean
that that day is um you know
very different but
you know just looking at
you know other days this is you know the
previous day
right you gotta buy here another buy
here all the way up right you got your
run here right can you live with taking
you know potentially getting short here
okay fine you know get short at 04. all
right i'm stopped up stopped out at you
know 08 09
but i had just bought here
you know at 14
all the way up to oh four
you know
maybe caught something here but didn't
start working out
started working out you know from 14 all
the way up to 20 but then sort of came
back down came back down okay fine you
seen the bearish bar come in here
and then
you know your stop would be in here but
you know hopefully you're trailing your
stop somewhere in here so you know
you're sort of around break even on this
trade maybe you'll lose a couple ticks
then it came back with a short here that
you could have got something on and got
it back you know this is a short from
you know what is that
0.05 down to double o at least
to at least cover some back
um you know a little bit back and forth
and again this is what the setting of
three
right now if i had a setting of one
now you notice right
i don't know it's probably there's
probably going to be some other signals
coming in here
okay
again going back down to the base level
up so you've seen
you know by here by here that were that
weren't there earlier right you got a
little short here you're going to buy in
a cell
and the short worked out this buy
you know you would have got stopped out
or you could take in your loss
um
now
i i did a video the other day it's on
the flow edges page about tick based
charts now you could use
tick based charts you could use volume
based charts you could use time based
charts you know people even ask
you know can i can i use you know
some other type of chart like hikanashi
and
it can let's just go back just go to
another market crude oil um
uh what i got the setting says is one
zero right
so
okay so one and zero
this is crude oil
change the chart type uh
no i i don't i haven't looked at this i
cannot see
today
um
again we'll just use the the base one
here one this is basically a two minute
chart
um you see it's calculating up there
i i don't know how it looks
so and you could see you know a little
by here before it fell over this was a
nicer buy here you know at the 40 area
all the way up to 70.
um a little by here and sell here a
little cell here coming in
um
you know some
little moves here and there
but you know
you can use it on different types of
charts you know
earlier in the morning session you know
nice
there's a sell signal here there's
another cell signal up here
there's a buy here
you know even
another here from up here you know the
80 area
8180 is a dollar move right down into 80
80.
so it really depends you know on your
chart type um
me
i'm more of a i don't say traditionalist
but you know
tick volume time based charts now
there's debates you know whether you
know
can you should you really be looking at
tick based charts because it sort of
distorts the volume well you're looking
at the number of trades
right as opposed to say a volume based
chart which you know obviously is based
on volume
um you know because a tick could be one
contract or the next it could be 300
contracts
and you're just closing bars based on
ticks so you know under the same
argument of time based
you know volume is going to vary in the
time based chart just as it does in a
tick based chart because you know
because some minutes you could have
three times more volume than the
previous one so yeah
i i hear people's arguments saying ah
you know tick based charts don't make
sense um it's just fine you know
everyone's got their own opinion in the
markets
um
you know in the user manual
i go through
sort of the different types of charts
that you can
you know look at
that i recommend you know the settings
for you know for example again it's not
a sexy market for by any means but you
know some of these grains
you know wheat especially
now you're probably not going to want to
use a 200 tick chart in in wheat i mean
you can but you know personally i find
you know something you know 25 or 50
tick chart is is nice but
you know you can see there's some
there's a nice move here
this morning in the weeds basically
804 up till i was at 813 where you got
the sell signal
and then back down but i personally i i
prefer to use um
on wheat
you know i use 25 i i use 50. i use them
but i look at them both i've got them
both open i got a lot of screen real
estate
then i could have multiple charts so
like today right this is the wheat today
you just you know this big sell-off
going down right
he had some buys up here you know 822
got all the way up crested up here at
824. then started moving down
right 820
down down down down down down down down
down to 8 14. people think you know oh
you know
what i'm not a farmer you know why do i
want to look at wheat well you got to go
where the opportunities are and grain
markets you don't get a lot of that
volatility fluctuation that you see in
nasdaq i mean you can trade nasdaq swap
a nasdaq chart right now i'm not going
to use a 50 tick chart we'll pull up mnq
uh m and q
where am i here
i mean cues obviously it's uh
you know it's going to be much more
volatile than something like wheat
i mean out of the grains soybeans is the
most volatile
um
although now we're sort of coming into
winter so it's probably going to calm
down a bit it's more volatile during the
summer now
mnq so
well i'll use a 30 second chart here
because it moves around a lot all right
you know it
sort of take you through
again you know some of the settings so
you get an idea
okay so again this is set at one
flow level of one
with a um
swing strength of zero okay so you can
see it's calculating here
up in the corner
and
again the first time i load it onto a
chart it might take a little while
whoops nice because i changed the uh
chart type
that was still loading so just bear with
it i'm sorry you know it's in real time
it's not slow it'll run in real time
it's just that
i put it on this computer today i mean
for this presentation i don't normally
on this pc i don't normally look at mnq
but anyway here we are okay
so
again open it up base settings
that is what comes programmed one and
zero
okay now let's go back to
cash
cash time cash me outside um
okay so just still in here right it
might be a little bit hard to see but
you know there's a cell here sell here
all the way down a group of buys in here
a couple cells here
i buy
some more buys up here some cells people
say oh you know like you know what is
this nonsense are there so many breaking
signals this because this market
nasdaq and mnq in particular are pretty
volatile markets
okay and setting it at basically the
lowest level for analysis is going to do
this right it's going to kick off a lot
of signals
so
one of the
ways to sort it
get around all these signals but rather
filter out
some of these noisy
noise generated signals
is by using
one
you can
use one or the other or both
go a higher level on the flow edge level
strength
or the swing strength right because
that's set at zero okay so
if you go higher you know again like i
said you know i use one three five nine
right so we'll go make it nine okay
which is
pretty high
i know some people that like to use
25 i think 20 or 25
okay so this is set at nine right see
it's calculating there and
so there's going to be less signals
right at a setting of nine as opposed to
a setting of zero because the zero
is basically you're just basically
looking for momentum right so you had to
buy here
a buy here and then a cell here all
right so again you know as a trader
okay so you got to buy here it started
to go up you know from the uh 050 16050
only went up to what 53 before it came
down stopped you out another buy here
again didn't stop you out but it
reversed over here okay so you know
you're getting long here from you know i
don't know called 60
and then you're getting short up here at
62 and a half or something like that
so yeah you lost a few points here
you had a small winner here
and then you had that nice big winner
here you know the move from 62 you know
down to 42 right even you had a chance
to add on here
all right now you know if you're not
familiar with the concept of adding on
to a position it's you know basically a
market's moving in your favor
and you're loading up you know so you
got
a sell signal here you're shorted here
at 62 62 and a half mark goes in your
favor pulls back a bit
more bearish order flow comes in you add
another one on
right at the 59 60 area in here so now
you got two on on this move down
okay
and again adding on
it's not for every trader because you're
taking on more risk
but at the same time i mean
once you understand the market and
you're in sync with the market when a
market is making its move
you know and if you could add on warp if
you have the wherewithal to add on
to a position
you know your result will be better as
long as it keeps going in that position
but if the market starts showing signs
of coming back
you're going to want to you know get out
right i mean you know
these you know over the last couple
years
you know the the new war cry is by the
dip
well
that's good when the market just dips
and rallies i mean honestly the way this
market's been for the last
couple years
you know that's a great strategy but you
know eventually
all this
money printing that's
basically given
causing the markets to keep rallying
anytime there's a dip that you buy it's
great
eventually that it's going to stop
right i don't hear anybody you know
then who knows once the market starts
selling off you know in a bear market
the rallying cry isn't going to be by
the dip it's going to be sell the rally
um
you don't hear people shouting that
but what would you rather do buy the dip
and if the market you know it used to be
the same don't
catch falling knives you know and now
everyone sort of ignores that and no you
got to buy the dip well really what you
should be doing is if the market is
selling off
and then the market you know comes back
and you know or even
has that order flow that's going in your
direction
go for it right lean on it right it's
going to give you you know a little bit
uh in my opinion it's going to give you
a little bit more bang for the buck now
again that's not a strategy you know
well mike says i should do that you know
and go do that
look at your trading results see how the
market reacts after you get into a trade
and find out you know do can your
account sustain
that activity
now
going back to so that was one and
nine right swing strength of nine so you
saw right obviously there was less
signals right you've seen a buy one buy
two buys three
uh one cell two cell so two and two
right
now
go back to you know the setting of one
and one and you're seeing remember
you're seeing a lot of signals coming in
you're seeing some you know cells a lot
of buys a lot of cells
um but i'm going to show you just you
know
you know sort of the difference
when you start looking at you know
the higher level
in
volume i'll show you in
volume what am i doing
okay so this again this is set at one
right you got those buys clumped in here
you know some more buys some cells
in here some cells down here if you make
the flow edge a little bit stronger
right from one to three and again
keeping the swing strength at zero
right
you're setting the threshold a little
bit higher right to um
in a sense stronger in reading
the order flow right finding out where
the value where the balance is and and
the order flow basically
so it has a slightly um
higher level stricter level in terms of
order flow so now you're seeing
um
you know less signals right you're
seeing a couple more a few buys in here
instead of seeing a bunch of buys coming
in here you're seeing a couple buys
right so it really depends on on your
trading style and and how you trade
whether you want to use
you know something as
one
three again you know personally
i'm not a big nasdaq guy i've never
really have been
i'm more into
sort of the traditional markets in the
sense of um you know interest rates you
know bonds buns
um crude oil you know commodities
commodities uh the cash settled markets
sorry not cash some of the physically
settled markets personally i think cash
level markets like you know these
financial instruments you know the
equity indices
um you know have sort of different
characteristics to their trading
because you know when you understand the
mechanics behind
the way these contracts
are
trade
and who the participants are
you you see sort of the the differences
in supply and demand
now yeah i had mentioned earlier about
the evening sessions right so again so
this is the
mnq
okay and
so what do i have this chart set at
three right three and zero
right three and zero okay so
evening sessions right overnight is what
i call evening is what i call overnight
right the overnight would be
um basically the
you know what you would consider the
european session
the evening session would be basically
the
asian session asian hours right because
you know the way the follow the clock
model goes on trading desk you know
follow the clock follow the sun so to
speak
asia europe u.s okay so you sort of have
the three defined um
trading periods now
during the day right a setting of
one
it's gonna really give you you know it
gives you a lot of signals
all right
but you tend to get a lot of noise
because some of these you know you see
these wicks in these bars right it's
just it's like these knee-jerk reactions
in some of these markets like nasdaq
especially
um
but if you're trading
i mean you can trade nasdaq at night
obviously it's got nice moves you can
see here four in the morning you know
here's a sell signal right in here you
know from what the 85 86 area all the
way down to you know the 60s
um you know then you get a little bit of
back and forth you know here uh you know
by from 71 you know and gets all the way
up into the 80s that's another 10 points
you get a lot of these 10 point moves in
nasdaq right here unfortunately there's
nothing
there's nothing to get you on this move
this morning but um you know there's
there's plenty of other
moves to be had in in the markets like
nasdaq etc now this is a one minute
chart
at night session
i'm sorry so this is set at three if you
go to one right a little bit lower
on the night session
let's give it a second here
evening all right asian hours basically
from seven until about midnight is you
know what you'd consider the asian then
one am till seven a.m
european session
market's a lot calmer in the sense of
you know activity you know during the
the u.s session trying to trade nasdaq
um you know can can really get you going
use a
i prefer to set it at one but i also
like to use a swing strength
because i'm looking for turning points
in the market
all right so for example this one i got
one and three
because really when i'm looking at what
if i'm trading in the evening session or
the overnight session
i'm looking for these turning points in
the markets
right and honestly you probably
shouldn't use a 30 second but chart
you could use a one minute chart is fine
i think in in the evening session
because again you know you want some
more volume
um again i don't follow nasdaq i mean i
watch it at night but it's not something
i'm active in
mini dao is good
um russell is good if you're into the
stock indices
crude oil is good
oh what else i mean you know e-minis but
i mean again you know if you're if
you're looking at things like
uh
russell and
mnq you know you don't really want to
look at e-minis so again this is e-minis
right so look at that settings that i
have this is this is this morning right
this is the
european hours so one and three let's
sort of take you back right
by using a swing
strength right it's looking for turning
points in the market right you have a
turning point here you have a turning
point here right you get the sell-off
here you get that sell-off now there's
going to be times where
um you know here's a nice buy in here
right okay the sell-off didn't happen
this buy you know probably stopped you
out
you know you're gonna have some times
where you do get stopped out sometimes
you know but again you really if you're
looking
at
swings
right it gets stopped out here like here
it is at 11 11 last night a short
opportunity okay stops you out next
trade comes back here from you know the
06 and a half area
boop another add-on right here six and a
half
i'm not saying that you would have got
out up here at six but you know maybe in
here for your first deeper pullback but
you're getting you know definitely in
here but then again you could have got
long again in here
right this is the asian hours which
historically is is
kind of quiet
right i mean look at this
you know again getting short in here you
know just sort of go sideways comes back
up you try to short again nothing
happens a third time's a charm right you
get short in here 07 right the signal is
coming this is a bearish order flow bar
this is the cell signal right here this
triangle right from o7
you know all the way down in here we get
a bullish signal
okay then you get a buy here
98.
no buy comes in here at 97. i'll show
you 87 rather 15 98
15 987
right
all the way up in here we get the sell
signal coming in okay
looks like a bigger move than it was but
it's still
you know five six handles right again
that's the asian hours
right
and again you know
mini dao
similar similar case right
now you know this was the
setting of uh what what it was i use in
there one and three
okay you could use one and three again
another way to do it
that's one way to make it a bit stronger
one and three um you know another way
you can do it is three and zero
right so you're looking for momentum but
with a strong
flow edge level so you could either have
a strong flow edge level
and
looking for moment momentum trades
with with strong
flow edges or you can use
a strong swing strength to sort of find
the market turning points in the market
right
so let's just change this to three and
zero
see how it looks
okay again this is just this is this
morning here so
let's
run it back here and this is mini dow so
obviously it trades a bit differently
moves are
different again you know from the 10 11
area up into the 20s um a cell here
let's buy and sell in here
some buys on this move up
by the dip no but um you know again
another nice move up another nice move
down but during the asian hours
again let's go back here to the asian
session pretty crappy right if you're
just looking at a normal bar chart right
some of these bars you can't get any
information out of it's because they're
too small all right imagine it's a 30
second ym chart
30 seconds you're trading one price
one price one price
and then you start seeing the activity
come in and when you start seeing
activity
well you want to notice whether that
activity is bullish or bearish
okay imagine
you you take this short here immediately
trades against you you get stopped out
fine okay
get a couple cell signals in here
doesn't go against you at all it doesn't
stop you out you could add on another
one in here
right right in here right see basically
getting short around this 85 ish area
trades all the way down you know there's
another cell here you're down into the
50s
so
you know that's
you know without going on and on and on
with all these different markets so in
the user guide
i talk about
all the different um
you know all the different settings in
there
that you know you can
you can use if i think i close my
powerpoint here
now
again so you know if you're interested
in the indicator you know the way you
get it you go to this page flow edges
www dot flow edges i'll put it in the
chat right then i'll get to the
questions
um again i made this video the other day
i haven't posted it up on youtube i've
just put it up on here i mean i should
throw it up on youtube but
it's about uh it's like a 20 minute
video here if you scroll down you can
use flow edges with you know equities um
crypto even if you use the coin you got
to use the coinbase um
connection
on ninjatrader
and you get it here right after this
launch period it's going to go back up
to 497. but right now it's at 325 okay
so again it's not overly expensive it's
a good deal
and again you know after this launch
period is over
next week it's going to go back to its
usual price of 4.97
now